not sure if you heard about this or not
it was kind of a little a small sort of
human interest story that the news was
talking about last night there was an
election they call it the midterm
election maybe you heard about it
results which I'm sure you also heard
Democrats took the house as expected
Republicans kept the Senate picked up a
few seats sort of not expected on that
and Democrats gained 28 seats in the
house made no gains in the Senate as
opposed to say the 2010 midterm
elections when obviously Obama was the
president and Republicans gained 63
seats in the house and I think five or
six in the seven so that was a red wave
this is not a blue wave as was
advertised and as we were promised not a
not a blue wave not a bloodbath wasn't a
red wave either wasn't a bloodbath in
the other direction now the spin doctors
are going to go to work and spin it one
way or another as they already have been
doing obviously but there weren't any
waves there were some there were some
ripples going in either direction which
is which is not what we were told
instead I think the Democrats did
basically what they had to do what they
what they what they were going to do
given the way that the map was drawn up
this time around there really wasn't
much chance or possibility that
Democrats would fail to gain the house
so that was going to happen it was
inevitable the question was whether
would be a trouncing and whether they
could seize control of the Senate at the
same time and the answer to that was no
one both counseling that is pretty it's
kind of incredible when you think about
it because as most people know the
midterms are historically unkind to the
party in power and then when you add on
top of that the unique factors that
Trump brings to the table being a
uniquely divisive president in that a
lot of people love him a lot of people
really hate him he's also unpopular
approval in the mid-40s whether you
whether you like him or not there's no
way around that in fact so that's
something that Democrats should have
been able to exploit but they weren't
happy able to they exploited it to some
extent but not to a very
large extent so you have to evaluate
this there victory in the house I didn't
get to evaluate it within the context of
what was expected and what the sort of
bare minimum was for them and in that
context I don't think it was certainly
was not a huge tsunami in their favor as
was predicted I think maybe they got a
few steps above bare minimum though
again we can't call it a big win for
Republicans either but I think when you
consider the Democrats and the
advantages that they had or should have
had going into this and the fact that
they you know we're only able to pick up
some seats in the house and actually
lost in the Senate and then also several
of their kind of up and coming rock
stars supposedly that that that they'd
put a millions of dollars into and they
brought celebrities down to campaign for
these people in Florida and Texas and
Georgia and all of those lost to their
if they're up-and-coming rock stars lost
many of them so when you consider that
it seems like the it seems clear to me
that there is still an obstacle in the
way for for Democrats that even though
now of course the rabid Trump haters the
really loyal Democrats they're gonna get
those people but it seems like there are
plenty of people who don't really like
Trump aren't necessarily big fans of the
Republican Party yet are hesitant about
supporting Democrats and why is that I
think that there are SEP there are many
reasons for this but let me just point
only point to up to it to a few number
one the the hatred for white men that
you see on the left I do in fact think
that this is a problem for for the
Democrats because there are around 100
million white males in America and they
don't especially like being constantly
cast as the villain and this liberal use
of white man as a pejorative has the I
would think not
very surprising effect of alienating
white men who are huge fans of having
their identity reduced to an insult and
to compound the problem on top of that
plenty of non-whites and non men
actually don't hate white men nearly as
much as Democrats seem to think and want
and expect and this may shock them to
learn but actually a significant number
of women love men and appreciate men so
resentment towards open resentment and
contempt for 100 million Americans is
let's say distasteful to most of those
100 million and to a good portion of the
other 225 million so I think that's a
problem for Democrats and a second
problem nobody cares about celebrity
endorsements okay I think Democrats rely
way too much on celebrities and on the
clout of celebrity to to to get the
results that they want you know you had
Oprah campaigning for Stacey Abrams in
Georgia you had and then she lost you
had Taylor Swift too much fanfare came
out and supported the opponent of Marsha
Blackburn in Tennessee he lost
there are many left-wing celebrities who
came out in favor of o'rourke and he
lost and then many more who were you
know trying to mobilize voters to
manufacture this big blue wave which did
not materialize so I think it turns out
that that in fact people don't really
care that much what what Oprah or Taylor
Swift or George Clooney thinks most
people are saying to themselves you know
or I should say most people are not
gonna say to themselves hmm I really
like Marcia Blackburn's policies but
then again I also really like that song
shake it off so I think I'll vote for
the other guy most people aren't doing
that so Democrats have massively
overrated the ability of famous people
to move the needle and I think actually
there's plenty of reason to believe that
the needle might be moved in the
opposite direction and then the third
thing this is really big especially in
this particular election and I think
this more than anything else explains
why the Democrats not only didn't gain
control the Senate but actually lost
seats in the Senate I think the number
one reason for that for sure
is Cavanagh which was you know the
democrat treatment of Kay and I said
this going into the I said this week I
said that this is going to be
big problem for the Democrats and I
think I was right about that the
Democrat treatment of Brett Kavanaugh
was not only one of the most vile smear
campaigns in modern American history but
I still think and I think clearly this
has been vindicated this I this this
perspective that it was also one of the
greatest political blunders in modern
American history because it turns out
that a lot of people do not really like
to see somebody dragged through the mud
and destroyed vindictively maliciously
on unsubstantiated allegations and
innuendo most people do not actually
delight as Democrats seem to do in the
personal destruction of innocent men and
I think on top of that a you know men
when they watch these kinds of witch
hunts unfold the first thing that we
that men think is well we feel really
bad for the man who's being targeted but
then also we think well what if that was
me and then women I think see this and
they think that was okay
what if that was my son what if that was
my my you know my brother or my husband
so Democrats insist that we believe all
women but normal people know that
sometimes women are lying and sometimes
men are not lying and so the more that
we did they they try to force us to see
it the other way I just think it doesn't
work
imagine if the Cavanagh soap opera had
never happened I think Democrats may
well have won the Senate in that case
then the fourth obstacle for Democrats I
think and I would just put this under
the broad category of madness the
Democrat Party has been come has been
become associated with rightly I think
madness PC madness and gender identity
madness and Tifa madness so there are
plenty of people who look at that and
they are viscerally instinctively on a
gut level repelled by it because it just
seems crazy to them they don't want to
be associated with these violent mobs
who are throwing Molotov cocktails and
everything there
polls show that over 80% of Americans
are fed up with political correctness
and the fact that the Democrat Party
owns political correctness and is sort
of the arbiter of political krytus
that's a problem for them because almost
everyone hates it and then the gender
identity stuff too I've been saying for
four years that this is a bigger problem
for Democrats and I think they realize
it's you know I don't think there are
very many people who are going to the
polls and they're number one number one
thing on their mind is they want to
oppose the liberal gender identity
crusade okay so it's not the the thing
that's foremost on people's minds but it
is there it is there that it's something
that people think about and when you've
got one side of the political aisle
insisting that men are women and that in
fact if a grown man wants to come into
the locker room with our daughter or our
wife or or our wife when they're
undressing and when you've got one
political party that's making that case
I think that has the effect again of
this are viscerally repelling a lot of
normal people who may otherwise agree
with Democrats on other issues and maybe
aren't big fans of Trump or whatever and
then the fifth big thing of course is
the Trump the Trump hate Democrats have
so much hatred for trouble are so
consumed by it that it's getting to the
point where you have to really hate
Trump as well
to that extent on that same level with
that same fury and passion or the
Democrats are going to alienate you
that's kind of what they demand they say
Trump is Hitler and they demand that we
all see it exactly that way where
there's no gray area there's no room in
between and that's scaring a lot of
people away and this leads into another
point where Democrats are consumed by
hatred for Trump even more than that the
Democratic base insists that its
representatives be consumed by hatred
for Trump so that is going to be an even
bigger problem for the next two years
for Democrats I believe they now control
the House of Representatives
so they have the ability now to launch
investigations and to file subpoenas and
to look at Trump's tax returns and do
all that kind of stuff and they've
already made it clear that they plan on
doing all of that if they want to go for
impeachment they could try to go for
that as well
and they're not gonna be able to help
from themselves the wheels of government
are going to grind to a halt even more
than they've already been at a halt for
the last several decades they're going
to grind to a halt and there is going to
be eating total dysfunction even more
dysfunction as as as as Democrats in the
house spend the next two years focused
entirely on their vendetta against Trump
just look at what they did to Cavanaugh
and they weren't even in power they
didn't really have the ability to
actually do anything to him but even
there they could not help himself and
they brought everything they could and
just dumped it on Cavanaugh true-false
doesn't matter they weren't cared and
they didn't they weren't worried about
the the truth of it they weren't worried
about anything like that they just
wanted to destroy him and so think about
that and then think about that times 100
for the next two years because I think
that's what we're in store for it is
it's not going to be good for the
country to have even more dysfunction in
government and to have a political party
that is focused only on destroying the
president not going to be good for the
country it's gonna be very bad for the
country but politically I think it it'll
it may be the best thing that could have
happened to the Trump actually maybe
sort of counter-intuitively I think once
once we get past in 2020 election and
the results are in I think we may look
back and say to ourselves that the thing
that sealed the deal was Democrats
taking control of the house in 2018
because people are just consider how
sick people were when they saw the
Democrat behavior towards Cavanaugh and
how fed up people were and these were
there were a lot of people that were fed
up and sick with fed up with it and sick
of it
who even maybe said to themselves you
know maybe Cavanaugh is guilty I don't
really know but this is just way
overboard and I can't support it so I
think they're gonna be a lot of people
who look at what the Democrats are gonna
do over the next two years
and they're gonna say yeah you know what
I'm not a big fan of Trump maybe he has
been corrupt or done these things I'm
not really sure but this is just way
overboard I don't want this to be the
sole focus of of of our political system
for for four years I think people are
gonna get sick of it and the Democrats
are not gonna be I'll help themselves
and they're gonna shoot themselves in
the foot all right
another points about elections yesterday
before the results came in I tweeted
something I mentioned this on the show
yesterday this point but I'm gonna
revisit it briefly this is what I
tweeted I said elections are important
but no matter who wins 99.999% of your
daily life in existence will be
completely unaffected by the results
today just a bit of perspective now this
tweet provoked a massive response like
3000 responses and Counting I think and
much of it was very angry people were
incensed liberals especially they were
incensed at the notion that their lives
don't necessarily hinge on the
machinations of politicians they were
mad that I would dare suggest that they
exist apart from election results and
that their existence will continue on
basically unimpeded no matter who's in
office many people told me that I'm just
a privileged sis hat man and I'm clearly
speaking from a position of bigotry and
cruelty etc and so forth but I posed the
question several times and I could not
really get a good answer I posed the
question I said okay give me some
specific examples of ways that your life
he's directly substantially quantifiably
armed by the politicians in office and
since most of the people that were
objecting were liberals I could make it
more specific and I said okay how have
Republic had Republicans who have
controlled the government for two years
controlled Congress controlled the
executive branch
they've been appointing judges and
everything so tell me over these last
two years how have you been directly and
personally harmed give me specific
examples and nobody could really do that
aside from I'll give you one typical
response somebody tweeted and said in an
attempt to answer this challenge said
they listed a bunch of ways that they've
been harmed apparently this is what they
listed healthcare clean water breathable
air freedom from violence education the
well-being of our neighbors the future
of our climate trade with other
countries tax rates ability to obtain
contraception Social Security and they
said that yeah 99% of your life isn't
affected if not if if that 99 percent
does not include any of those things
implication being that Republicans have
heard us on all of the levels that were
just outlined there now of course the
suggestion that a person has not been
able to breathe or drink water since
Republicans took office is obviously
let's say a bit of an exaggeration one
might even call it a hysterical lie and
it does bring up the question of how are
you still alive after after two years of
this if you haven't been able to breathe
and you haven't gotten a break from
violence you haven't been able to drink
and or any of that for two years so it
seems like you have actually survived
somehow in spite of all that now but but
this this echoes the the utterly
hysterical delusional claims from many
other people who say that their lives
have been hanging in the balance and and
have been have been greatly harmed by
what's been going on in Washington now
if these were unborn children responding
then I would have to agree because
unborn children their lives really do
hang in the balance depending on what
laws are passed but as for born people
in modern America my point is simply
that our well being doesn't
not substantially hinge on what
politicians say and do and the fact that
despite all of the hand wringing despite
all of the panic from Democrats and
liberals Republican Trump got into
office we had Republicans controlling
Congress and things worked out okay for
them like they they're still alive
they're still living their life they
they don't live in a in a dictatorship
despite what they claim because they can
do what they want they can say what they
want they can dig just they can carry
about however they want
in fact we've learned that they can even
go in the streets and throw rocks and
burn buildings and they won't
necessarily even get arrested for that
so they've got a ton of freedom they've
got arguably more freedom than they
should have which only proves my point
that yes elections are important and and
politicians have the ability to cause
harm yes but but not nearly to the
extent that that we seem to think
judging by our reaction to elections
because every election that the the side
that loses will act as though life as
they know it is over but then life
continues and and most people just
continue on and and in their daily lives
they wouldn't really even be able to
tell who's in control of the government
or who got elected to office because it
really has no bearing on most of what
they do throughout their life and
throughout their day I said 99.99% of
what you do throughout your day you know
based on that you wouldn't be able to
tell who's in office and I think that
that's true really what I'm trying to
communicate here and what I'm trying to
convey is that we have freedom actually
and it's a testament to the to our
founders who set up this system that
even when there is so much incompetence
and so much dysfunction even in spite of
that we still have freedom and we could
still live our lives those of us who are
born which is quite a caveat I realized
but that's what I'm talking about
right now it's it's it's interesting to
me that people are so resistant to this
idea that people could be angry and
offended simply because I said that they
have freedom and they can still live
their lives and their life will not be
over just because the politician that
they wanted to get an office didn't get
in why would someone be angry at that
I'm trying to it's I'm trying to
encourage you and say you'll be fine
really I promise you have freedom but it
seems like people don't want that
message and they don't want to to
realize that they have freedom people
are and the only explanation I can think
of for that is that people don't even
though people have freedom they don't
really want it and they don't want to
believe that they have it and they don't
want us to believe that they have it
because the the only rationale I can
think of the only way to explain it is
that they're just looking for excuses in
their life because with freedom caught
becomes a certain amount of
accountability and responsibility you're
responsible for your life and there are
a lot of people in America who do not
want to be responsible for their own
lives don't want to take the blame for
anything and so that's why they make
this absurd claim they speak in this
apocalyptic manner about about elections
and politicians and policies and
everything else because they don't want
freedom and so I'll tell you even though
we do not right now live in a
dictatorship and we still largely have
freedom when we get to the point in
America where a large number of people
don't want freedom and would prefer not
to have it and are in fact trying to
convince themselves they don't have it
well that's that's when you do get into
a dangerous point and I think if we if
we continue on if we persist in that
mentality and that philosophy then who
knows maybe years down the line we won't
have freedom maybe we maybe we really
will live in a dictatorship because it
seems like that's what everybody wants
so that's something to be careful about
one more thing I wanted to
to mention relating to the results last
night and getting away from Republican
versus Democrat there was an interesting
vote in Florida
they voted to restore voting rights to
felons so that a felon who gets out of
jail completes whatever additional
requirements are necessary that at that
point they can then get the vote back
and be reinvigorated violent sex felons
they will they will not be they won't
they're an exception but everybody else
can vote again and I think that that's
that that's the right call and that's
how it should be in every state I think
I think it's pretty absurd actually that
we disenfranchise people who commit
crimes forever for the rest of their
life they can never vote again even if I
mean let's say you take a guy who at the
age of eighteen falls in with the wrong
crowd commits a robbery or something
felon that's a felony it's a serious
felony goes to jail as well he should
and then gets out after four or five
years or whatever and then even fast
forward the clock to the guy is now 60
years old and he committed this crime
when he was 18 he got out of jail he's
been out of jail for 30 years or more
but the way the law works in a lot of
states he still can't vote maybe he's
had a job he's been a contributing
member of society you know got a college
education still can't vote because if
something had happened 3040 years ago I
think that's crazy
I just think it is once you've served
your time and you've paid your debt
Society I think the just and right thing
is to let someone then go and live and
move on and if someone has committed a
crime that is so heinous that they can
never really repay the debt and that
they should face lifetime consequences
for well then that's someone who should
still be in prison in my mind
this is one of my I don't wanna get
sidetracked here this is one of my big
problems with the sex offender registry
now I like the idea of knowing where sex
offenders are but if you're telling me
that someone has committed a crime that
is so heinous that that the that now
they are they're a threat to society for
the rest of their lives and I can't even
trust you know I I need to know where
they live so that I can make sure that
my kids never go anywhere near that
house
well it seems to me that's someone who
should still be in jail right if it's
someone who needs to be on a registry
than what you're telling me is that
they're still a threat so they should be
in jail if they're not a threat anymore
then they shouldn't be on a registry so
there should be no need for that and I
think of the same thing with voting if
you're telling me that this is someone
who has done something so terrible that
they should have their their voice taken
from them politically for the rest of
their lives then it seems like that's
someone who should still be in jail but
if they did something that doesn't
really justify those kinds of lifetime
consequences then once they get out of
jail then they should be able to return
to the life and I say this as someone
who is not you know I'm not one of those
people as I've made clear I'm not one of
those people that believes that we need
to get everybody out to the polls and
that America our democracy is is
benefited just by shoving the the you
know the the the highest number of warm
bodies into the polling station that we
can I don't think that at all
in fact I'm in favor of disenfranchising
some people I'm in favor of
disenfranchising people who are
oblivious who who don't know anything
about our government about the system
about the candidates that they're voting
for if there was a way to weed them out
and disenfranchise them I would but a
felon who does not fall into that
category I see no reason why they
shouldn't be able to vote in fact
someone who's someone who's been in jail
I think that they have seen the system
from the inside literally and so they
have a perspective that I actually think
it's kind of
valuable in the in the voting booth it
may be I'm sure it's a sort of cynical
perspective about the government but
good I think we could use more cynical I
think we can use more people who are
cynical about government in the voting
booth come election day so I think
they're valid their perspective is
valuable even if you don't think it's
valuable that still does not justify
removing the vote from them so I think
that Florida got that one right all
right we'll leave it there thanks for
watching thanks for listening everybody
Godspeed